given that it is a Thanksgiving I want
to know what qualities you are thankful
for in each of your fellow coaches like
Ivan no length or too long
blade is my buddy just kidding I love
you Blake
kinda yes sometimes I love Eve like ish
did gwen stefani just say what we think
she said et caught up with Adam Levine
and Gwen Stefani to find out what they
are most thankful for in their fellow
Voice coaches sure some answers we
expected for us awesome and he's such a
genius but this one we did not like I
don't know like are too long Blake is my
buddy just kidding I love you Blake
kinda ish sometimes I love to black-ish
context it's a love fest at the voice
and the same rings true for pals Adam
and Gwen - I'm just so grateful that I
got to know Adam because it's weird
because he's such a good person
he's literally so smart and he's so
witty and talented and I've just learned
so much hug it out guys I feel like I've
I've met these people that I've become
friends with that also kind of do what I
do which is so cool it and I've made
incredible friendships and Pharrell and
Gwen and I mean everyone I worked with
on the show it's been super cool even
Blake
you